I'll ride a ride I'm going I'm going so
the supposed final trailer for Justice
League has come out and I have some
thoughts on it and ultimately I'll spoil
where I'm going with this I'm gonna
explain why I've come to the conclusion
that I'm actually gonna go see this
movie now and now for you who are
waiting for me to go because this
trailer is so awesome yeah that's that's
not the reason why the trailer is okay
there's ups and downs but let me talk
about those and I'll even to where I'm
going in terms of why I'm now actually
gonna go see this movie
so the first thing is it starts out made
me think of Field of Dreams actually
starts out you know with Lois dreaming
and there's Superman in this cornfield
and it's it's all very you know just
getting a sense of the loss of him and
it's it's funny because it's what we
should have for the loss of Superman
except that it feels like they're
mourning a Superman that was not the
Superman they'd actually been giving us
in the two movies he'd eat appeared in
and maybe they're just kind of hoping to
like cause a Nelson Mandela effect and
you like change the way that we remember
that he acted as a character prior to
that I don't know we'll see but it was
it wasn't bad it was intriguing it was
nicely framed and then it then then we
got like the whole news reports you know
violence and terrorism and all the stuff
is up you know numbers are up and the
hope is is fading from the world and my
immediate thought was you know what this
world didn't seem like a world I would
ever want to live in already it seems
like a really dark bleak not
particularly pleasant place to live so
when you tell me that it's now gotten
even worse he kind of leave me going is
this a world I actually care about if
he's saved or not cuz I mean that's
that's the thing as far as your stakes
go
whatever the heroes are protecting needs
to be something worth saving and the way
well in this world has been built if
they're if they're emphasizing it's now
worse than it was last time we saw it I
mean like in terms of escalation scale
and stakes I understand why it's worse
in terms of all that but just I'm left
thinking boy at this point he almost
just kind of wants a you know what let
the world fall apart we'll start fresh
and try again but and then we get you
know we get to see you the various
characters they I do like this song
choice for effort and it's on the nose
it's cheesy the use of a cover of Heroes
which is a great song but for whatever
reason I don't know what it is I like
this better than the use of come
together from the trailer a few months
back for whatever reason that one didn't
really click for me this one which is in
a very similar vein very on the nose
it's a more modern sounding cover for
whatever reason is kind of working for
me I think maybe it's because like the
song choice is cheesy and I don't mean
that as a criticism I mean that in a
good way I mean that ain't no trait in
it I mean it's cheesy in and embracing
yeah it's silly but come on have fun
with us and there was something about
come together that felt more like aren't
we so cool yeah I don't know I'm reading
into song choices and trailers now you
know I'm watching that there's a heck of
a lot of red sky and that does for me
that doesn't make the effects look great
yeah cyborg carrying Aquaman that you
know that was a neat little moment I'm
really not digging the vibe off of this
Aquaman but whatever I'm surprisingly
like liking this flash the more I'm
seeing of him so that's nice it's the
trailer in a vacuum if this was the
first trailer I would I would probably
be much more skeptical than I thought I
am in this video right now and I
probably wouldn't be rushing out to see
this and even now I'm not necessarily
rushing out to see it opening day but I
do think I am actually gonna see this
movie now and that has to do with
basically a couple of factors the two
main reasons
that I had previously decided I was not
going to see this film the first was I
was pretty much dead certain that I was
going to hate every second of it and
then the second was that I didn't want
to financially support the version of DC
characters that Warner Brothers was
putting into film both of those have
effectively been changed the the first
is while I'm not necessarily believing
I'm going to go in enjoying this movie I
now have a reason kind of beyond just
hoping I get a version of these
characters I like because at this point
this thing has gone through so many
alterations so many rewrites you know it
was it was clear very early on that
immediately off the back of BBS they
were already trying to make it lighter
and you know that was in the middle of
shooting and then Schneider left and
Joss Whedon came in and there's
obviously whole new plans for the
directions of the DC EU as a whole so at
this point I'm just kind of fascinated
to pick this thing apart I'm gonna be
really interested to sit in a theater
and sort of figure out for myself
okay this element here is that something
that was in there originally oh this
this feels more like in line with what
they say they're doing now so I bet
that's something newer that feels Snyder
that feels Whedon and I have a bit of a
morbid fascination in terms of just
seeing how this thing is all gonna come
together now if it manages to surprise
me and actually be good and enjoyable
you know what that'll be amazing I have
no expectation of that at this point but
I think as opposed to any my personal
assessment if you like the movie fine
but as opposed to bvs which for me was
just a mess like there were a couple of
decent elements but overall was just a
mess this I think is gonna be something
that is just gonna be fascinating
not necessarily entertaining at least
not to me to my sensibilities but just
fascinating did just sort of go well
that's not something you would have
gotten under normal circumstances and
you know I think that'll be interesting
and then into my second reason what at
this point one of the most viewed videos
on my channel was my Mary
angry rant against Warner Brothers and
the DC EU which concluded with me saying
I wasn't gonna give the money anymore
if I gave them my money then Warner
Brothers would interpret that as oh what
we're doing works and they would keep
doing it however at this point that's
not really the case and it's been made
very clear by numerous people from
Warner Brothers involved in the various
DC movies currently in production that
they are DMM made a video about this
already they are D emphasizing the
shared universe nature they're focusing
more on the individual franchises the
thing as a whole is very obviously being
moved in a new direction and that to me
says it's fine for me to see this move
because they're already moving the
franchise as a whole away from what it
was that I wasn't liking so if this film
is not actually going to be determining
what the direction of the DCU is anymore
they're already heading somewhere else
then I don't feel like mine giving my
money to this film is saying I want more
of this dark brooding depressing thing
cuz they seem to have already realized
that they need to alter that so at this
point I'm ok
chucking at my 650 yeah yeah I have a
very cheap movie theater so yeah that's
that's ultimately where I land following
this most recent trailer what at what
are folks thinking was this new trailer
a significant improvement was that a
setback wasn't about the same for you
did it impact your decision to go and
see this movie while it is in theaters
whatever your thoughts are on any of
this drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher I'm also one half of
the punch like a girl podcast on the
fire and water podcast network at fire
and Water podcast calm until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]